all right you freaks just hold it if you
really want to tangle with someone why
not try your luck against the Wolverine
Hugh Jackman has one last outing as the
feral rage machine Wolverine coming in
2017 it's hard to imagine anyone else
playing the character save for being too
tall he was perfect for the role
particle readers you know if you could
shrink himself down a foot you would
it's a shame he never got to go all out
with an r-rated solo Wolverine movie now
that would have had fans and a frenzy
the gore has always been a big part of
the character and it's sad to see I'm
always getting nerfed to a pg-13 badass
in the films it's like having someone's
only superpower be cutting people's
heads off and you make him the star of a
kids show what good is he then an x-men
origins Wolverine is probably the lowest
point for Jackman's career as the
character so far that movie has gone
down in history as one of the worst
superhero films for so many reasons but
I'm here today to tell you that maybe
something good came out of it I present
to you a classic example of a happy
accident The Wolverine game that
satisfies every complaint we had from
the movie except one but I'll get to
that later production delays led the
film to take much longer than expected
with weather being erratic Hugh Jackman
being busy with prior engagements and
the screenplay still being written while
they were filming it all of this had the
producers requesting that the presumably
shitty video game tie-in be delayed in
its release as well
therefore the developers had months of
downtime with a finished game and
nothing to do but polish its claws all
of this extra time helped them turn out
a great final product that surpasses the
awful material it was licensed by from
the opening cutscene alone we were all
surprised to see that this game
immediately has a much better set up in
presentation than the film with a scene
taking place in the Days of Future past
era
character the visceral gore and gritty
tone of this scene sets the stage for a
ride of hacking and slashing that we'll
never get to see on the big screen after
Logan narrates the line that is
different every time I hear it for some
reason I'm the best there is at what I
do at least the people still living
after I'm done do you see that it cuts
back to his days as a soldier for Weapon
X then cut to UM stabbing a guy so hard
a crater forms dad well a more general
synopsis is that this game has the plot
of the film with all of the scenes
redone to be way more entertaining
everything from the film still happens
sadly but they did the best they could
to turn into a Gore field rocket ride my
best example is the fight to escape the
Weapon X facility in the film Wolverine
fights a roomful of people and then
instantly gets outside to see the light
of day
well how threatening is that which never
happened in the books but whatever in
the game Wolverine is poisoned loses his
healing ability is cured by some random
doctor with a conscience saves a little
girl who can teleport fights a bunch of
prototype monster things and escapes
into the frozen Canadian wilderness
through a massive floodgate it takes
events that happen over less than 30
seconds in the movie and makes it a
grueling battle for supremacy against a
wave of enemies that never seems to stop
it also serves as a way to put some
thought back into the thoughtless story
and fix the happy tone you could argue
is just an excuse to have it be a video
game where you kill tons of nameless
dudes with your deft Kanak knuckles but
I think these add-ons are what makes it
a better experience than its counterpart
I really appreciate the hidden audio
logs that provide some background on all
the characters and events that's not
something they needed to put in a game
like this but it's nice that they did
and it makes the experience a little
more full the only major point of
diversion from the film is when
Wolverine just kind of forgets about the
plot for a while and goes to raid a
military base inside
Mesa that turns out to be a sentinel
factory and hey look it's bolivar trask
boy you want to talk about the x-men
story having continuity errors look at
the differences with Trask every time
you see him angry looking black guy less
angry looking black guy than ah ah he
must be doing something new with his
hair he looks good for his age
the game provides a valid reason for
bolivar trask to dislike mutants and
plants the seeds for Days of Future past
this game's story also proposes an
origin for Nightcrawler by suggesting
that teleporting will.i.am and mystique
are his parents I know that the next
movie to come out immediately shut down
this idea and screwed up the continuity
even further but I like that they are
being creative and trying to make
something new with x-men lore also it's
a godsend that mystique is wearing
clothes for once that whole idea of her
being naked and um smooth was only a
thing for the movies that's so stupid
like can't she just use her powers to
make clothes the improvements don't just
stop at wardrobe fixes and added scenes
they also do a great job of recreating
poorly done scenes what was undoubtedly
the film's silliest fight scene is made
into an epic chase sequence that goes on
to the point of being insane instead of
fighting gambit in an alley with goofy
looking effects he fights him through an
entire Hotel and Casino and on top of a
collapsing construction site with police
helicopters watching and on top of a
neon sign that's exploding geez gambit
you think you overreacted a little this
is a minor misunderstanding that led to
somewhere in the ballpark of a few
billion dollars in property damage
people died man
no wonder they recast you as Channing
Tatum dumb ass so let's get to the meat
and adamantium bones of this game time
to get to work how is the gameplay well
Wolverine basically has over 500 methods
killing nameless army guys you may think
400 methods was enough but it wasn't so
here's a scene where he pushes a guy's
head into some helicopter blades you
know
I distinctly remember always feeling bad
for this pilot when killing him he looks
so afraid and gives you this the head
shake like please don't kill me in a
spectacularly gory fashion mr. mutton
chops and daddy issues I don't deserve
this
wonder if that pilot had a family that
he was taken care of maybe as a kid he
always dreamed of flying helicopters and
and Weapon X was the only place hiring
at the moment and his son little a
variation needed food on the table maybe
this guy's parents and family never find
out what happens after the helicopter
crashes maybe it's worse if they do
Jesus Wolverine aren't you thinking
about any of this stuff first night
you're too busy trying to think up new
ways to string someone's intestines
across an entire forest in less than an
hour so this game sure gives Wolverine
fans a massive dose of that cathartic
violence they've been itching for and
Hugh Jackman lends his face and voice to
it giving a sense of authenticity after
I kill Victor I'm coming for you any one
of the animal curl well you got it
there are medium combo strong combos
grab attacks and a load of environmental
hazards you can use to vary the fight
throwing people into forklifts explosive
containers cement mixers and basically
any tree branch that's pointy enough
gives you a real sense of the savagery
associated with the character that's not
to ignore the excessive finishing moves
you can form and the amount of limb
removal that borders on being just
flat-out wacky there's not a ton of
grace or subtlety to this rampage quest
I think that's something that got
especially right with this game there's
a certain charm to the dumb bluntness of
Wolverine unlike a typical drooling
monster like the whole Logan is
perfectly capable of fitting into
society talking through his issues and
using his brain to get past a rough
situation that doesn't mean he's going
to do any of those things but he's
capable of it
the game makes reference to this in
scenarios where you can't just cut your
problem and it forces you to start
thinking like a civilized human being
man what the hell a puzzle where I have
to use portals to get out of this
science base hidden anime sir
what is this a game where that sort of
thing would happen I guess it is
actually references aren't jokes oh my
god there's so much everything happening
right now what do I even do the game has
a fairly simple upgrade system and a set
of perks you can add to boost Wolverines
effectiveness so if you want a certain
type of build you can go for it
I find myself gravitating towards
boosting the healing abilities and
making him take less damage I also love
the healing effect in this game it's the
first one I've ever seen to do anything
like it Wolverine can be blown to pieces
and still keep brawling there are points
where he's so damaged from the waist up
that you can't see a patch of skin
anywhere and he just keeps going I
remember they used a similar effect for
the Deadpool game a couple of years
later and it still looks just as good
sure your health can run out because
it's a video game you have to be allowed
to die but it takes a lot for that to
happen now I know what you're thinking
but surprisingly you don't often feel
overpowered because they throw so many
enemies at you to compensate for how
unbelievably tough you are
so if balance is out the boss is range
from fighting a rock monster or a
Wendigo monster most of the time which
can get really boring really quickly but
the fights against actual characters are
much more interesting the undisputed
highlight of the game is the fight with
the Sentinel the only thing missing from
this scene is the 90s x-men team song
blasting at full volume
ah
the spacing between the boss fight
starts to get a little weird though
right after the Sentinel fight is a
fight with the blob in a King Soopers
and after that is a fight with gamut the
boss fights make a great use of
environment and all have something
special about them though they could
have been put a little farther apart so
the player doesn't get all the goods in
one place another feature I adore is the
secret items if you collect two of these
hidden action figures you unlock what we
have all been craving since the year
2000 what would you prefer yellow
spandex where it just wear the damn suit
why won't you do it look at what they
have Chris Evans wearing he's
practically just an American flag and he
looked badass just put on the damn
costume in the last movie we all want it
can't believe they teased us so bad with
that deleted scene and never committed
to it
bastards any way you select it in the
bonus menu and then they drop you in
this creepy looking arena and you're
wondering what am I doing here is this
going to be some kind of prison shower
scene when suddenly another Wolverine
wearing the costume shows up and you
have to fight him to the death to get a
suit in the manual there is a boss where
Wolverine fights himself and you can do
it again for all three costumes forget
the wife beater and acid wash jeans this
is what a badass whereas in the battle
yeah
so what are your thoughts on the new
duds there's some kind of damn superhero
fashion show cuz I got some orange of
brown tights that would you to shame
how does Wolverines hair grow back when
he's been blown up his healing factor
works on his hair how does it know when
to stop growing well what if he wants to
grow it out and cut it off again
shouldn't he have like Rapunzel hair or
if he gets blown up shouldn't he be bald
for a little while hey maybe that guy
with the red shirt and the swords knows
the answer
oh wait oh the one thing this game
couldn't fix
Deadpool becoming a Mortal Kombat
character at least you get to beat the
[ __ ] out of this abomination yourself
while angrily quoting things about Bea
Arthur and chimichangas I can't believe
something like this happened I used to
be more chatty than this I guess you're
not the Merc with the mouth anymore
you
it's such a blatant disrespect of a
character in the name of keeping him
from upstaging the other two guys they
took away a source of power it's all
wrong it's like his spider-man was a
tired old man and shot lasers out of his
wrists instead of webs looking at it
from the point of view of the developers
they had their hands tied and couldn't
change something so drastically from the
movie so they just made it a fun boss
fight for what it's worth and at least
we all know the Deadpool character would
bounce back from it eventually in a solo
thing that captures his essence well
looking on the bright side this game has
a more interesting version of the movies
terrible plot gameplay that addresses
all complaints about the watered-down
portrayal of the character and a
performance by Hugh Jackman that we all
wanted out of him - still haven't gotten
the only downsides to the game are that
it gets a bit repetitive in the last few
missions and the enemy variation slows
down dramatically by then we get
occasional flashbacks to his crazy
antics in Africa that are so much less
interesting than the stuff in the future
the difficulty curve gets a little wonky
in the second-to-last level and it
starts to feel like a chore to get
through it but when you do it's smooth
sailing from there my hope is that the
Deadpool movie will do really well and
let the studio know that r-rated
superhero movies can turn a profit
making Fox consider a rated-r finale for
the legendary portrayal of the world's
angriest Canadian you sure as hell
didn't work out like we planned
that doesn't mean you enough this world
may be broke
for now the game is a badass love letter
to a classic comics character in an
overall competent character action game
I think it's definitely worth a play if
you happen to be a fan of the character
like this genre of game or just wish
x-men origins was better I'm a Wolverine
and my hatred keeps me warm a Wolverine
show you rush until next time friends
always remember go [ __ ] yourself
oh and also wear the suit you effeminate
Australian